[Applaudissements]
sanaa les arts et les gants mais rooney
qui joue bien d'une bar mitsva j'attends
look novateur mais on dirait le serveur
du bar des traits et alors là si chalon
traiteur normalement il passe comme ça
c'est de merguez vous l'aimez pas moins
que c'est regarder ça petit alors qu'est
ce qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est l'anti
sommaire la houlala
je peux vous dire que cyril j'ai le plus
gros dossier sur vous c'est une photo
qu'on m'a envoyé ce que l'indiquent
savait qu'à ces sources sans quoi on ne
l'a jamais vu dans toute l'histoire ne
touche pas à mon poste photos de moi oui
juste une photo de moi que vous même
vous la connaissez pas un très beau
dossier syrien vraiment mais je pense
que l'on n'a pas vu dans les centres
dpmm vous la connaissez pas c'est en
soit ces photos c'est une photo de moi
que je ne connais pas oui je pense que
je peux me faire virer après la
diffusion de séries de juste une petite
question avant de montrer la photo
oui à quel moment vous êtes dit j'arrête
là tchèque koukal j'arrête le couscous
prime parce que vous étiez très fin très
beau gosse regardez la photo c'est
exceptionnel photo c cette photo est
l'époque il était très jeune et oui
comme cette photo mais c'est tout ce qui
compte
mais je crois que c'était un club de
vacances vacances étaient prouvées ouais
c'est ton ex patron de man c'est vrai
que j'étais très sceptique est il
ailleurs en espagne justement on l'a
jamais vue dans le sens de tpm et gégé a
raison vous êtes fait greffer des poils
oui et là vous n'êtes contre et c'est
l'herbe sans rigoler c'est vrai c'est
vrai que je suis à quel âge il a pas
déjà en vacances et bernard montiel
mais au dossier et le bagne le bas nous
voilà déjà devant lille et je ne tiens
pas je suis de vendre je vous tiens pas
je suis têtu déjà l'abruti alors mieux
vaut préférer maintenant comme ça à bâle
comme ça attendez un très beau gosse
pour vous dire que cet été là ça régale
et fait extrêmement mal pour vous dire
qu'on joue mais bon je vais passer à la
piscine ou quand je passais à la
discothèque de vacances les strings
claquer des oyats alors la cgt joue au
tennis je lui ai dit ma mère avait ni
celui qui se levait le plus tôt du club
bavarois mais qui se coucher plus tard
et j'ai le revenu hier soir la vérité si
je mens 3 vachement bien ouais merci
merci je sais que vous avez vu ça elle a
tendance à dire qu'ils avaient les
chiffres radio qu'elle est tombée
[Rires]
bravo pour la photo avec trouver même si
vous me torturer je ne donnerai pas ma
source ce qu'on aura peut-être une autre
la semaine prochaine
et oui mais d'abord je voulais diffuser
un magnéto sur plusieurs chroniqueurs
man plusieurs en même temps vous allez
comprendre pourquoi un joueur c'est
plusieurs vous allez comprendre habitude
on se concentre sur un chroniqueur mais
là en fait je me suis baladée dans les
coulisses cette semaine est en fait vos
amis chroniqueur cyril ont des délires
parfois très bizarre pendant que lui
apprendre à prendre ou à laisser ça
pendant que vous êtes dans à prendre ou
à laisser et pas que mes rôles regardez
là je suis tombé et en voulait se mettre
dans la peau de thé au lavabo
c'est celui qui fait chaud ici un poil
atta c'était très très très gênant
regarde je suis ton grand
[Musique]
non
on a d'autres choses à gérer la donation
est bien c'est que j'ai trouvé mon style
vous vous avez fait vous avez pris à
savoir castanet énormément c'est
difficile ça mouille énormément et ça
lui va très bien
guillaume playboy est énormément tuque
s'est récemment fait partie comment
maintenant je prends soin à des noms
mais ça sert ya des gens à les meufs
adore ça les recharges la combi ça donne
des ombres et des lois la marsa réel oui
bien sûr là par contre on y voit
beaucoup moins les voix du slip on
arrêté pour un fait du sert et de la
décote non il nous arrivait coque n'ont
pas eu besoin des décors allez merci
c'est bon merci à l'étranger vous savez
que vous étiez un très grand chanteur
oui oui je sais que j'étais un très bon
chanteur cyril a fait une entrée
fracassante dans les bacs cette semaine
avec son nouvel album c'est que ça
s'appelle la compil de baba c'est que
cette couleuvre et en exclusivité la
toute nouvelle compil de babar toutes
les plus grandes chansons chantées par
baba avec balbeli auto
j'avais mais aussi jolie nana est mort
des bêtes bête bête je suis tombé la
première nerh nerh et pour finir à
l'anzhi ou oman au mois le mois et en
bonus track deux titres originaux écrits
et son départ si la nina bobos on fait
moins qu bo bobo gaucho bobo bon c'est
moi q ainsi que des titres qu'ils
dénoncent
isa l'adjoint je me fais quête sur sévit
partout où je vais je me fais qu'être en
laponie je me fait qu'ai je fait qu'être
sur rémy veut piquer sur m6 joue au
poker à las vegas
hu
déjà c'est isa paysage isaac choix les
adjoints
déjà la toile à pau dit je sais ça fait
flipper tout fait prochaine boulot
derrière toi mais s'accaparer les
abattoirs
c'est peu cher et on pense
d
on va la réécouter trait au lard écoulée
fois numéro un sur ce point
[Applaudissements]
ces leçons de l'année quoi attendez que
c'est ma candidature c'est celle à
laquelle folie on aura une semaine
prochaine semaine et on espère que cela
sera surélevée de droit dans des fuseaux
luna alors je le dis on a le droit qu'on
sait de la parodie un malouin studio ses
data vault 10 ouais d'accord vous me le
confirmer quand ce n'était pas aux dieux
valois en allant voir jouer mais alors
si rtl le diffuse trois à quatre fois
pas là je vais demander à laurent
briquet donc diffusée dans les grosses
têtes dedans c'est sûr
je suis sûr que je suis sûr que difool
me la passera sur aulas pour dit je me
fixe alors bien entendu isabelle on
partagera les droits de wima et mais je
vous les donne
ring de nos résidents alors quoi je vous
le dis et je le dis faudra bien sûr le
clip on donnera les droits d'auteur a
una société où le dynamisme et en plus
je dis bonjour le duo des balles à
examiner ce message allez allez c'est
bon allez merci général et merci j'ai
bien rigolé après cette magnifique
compile de baba je suis devrait parler
de rené malleville chaque semaine je
vous monnaie il va venir tout à l'heure
et oui je vous mets en colère il est
colère mais c'est aussi un coût qui nous
je vous montre toutes les semaines dans
lundi qu' après tiffany bonvoisin après
s'il tient la corde et maîtrise des
chroniqueuses après virginie ledoyen
après isabelle morini bosc
bref la liste est interminable rené à
une nouvelle target
non c'est audrey la nouvelle contre x de
tp on est à fond de sa pas peur la
papeterie est obligés sinon tu finis en
prison isabelle au dos il faisait si
[Musique]
elle est bien
les accabler moi j'ai un beau gosse
aulas leur monomère raout et c'est quoi
cette nouvelle amm oeuf camomille
building on petit je croque concept e
cuisse je le vois bien gouttes de ma
bouillabaisse de plus j'ai un beau gosse
puis tous ces magnifiques
il me va te serrer 20 il a peur de ma
langue en plus
au même moment mais ces trois sites meuf
optique juridique est alors merci d'être
là et j'aurai un petit truc à vous dire
sur miss france un instant jauni ça peut
être chaud pour but et les miss france
c'est magnifique et qui sera là là là on
a deux longtemps de trôner d'amour
exceptionnelle du flipper il y va éroder
et de bernard et fils mais il fait mal a
quand même cinq mecs qui rendra la en
même temps le képi rhône est là mais les
autres sont à la porte quand je
cherchais un chroniqueur royal à nouvel
ordre et je voudrais je sais j'ai connu
généralement ils sont et ils sont
vraiment à dos par un maire monte à
lille et well et surtout il l'interpellé
ouais elle est charmante et les
sympathiques et par delphine wespiser
justement vous tout à l'heure aussi j'ai
eu une révélation vous faire il ya un
animateur très très très connu on a
envoyé un mot pour vous il m'a dit que
je pouvais lire à l'antenne on m'a dit
que je pouvais lire à l'antenne il est
fou amoureux de vous mais c'est sérieux
c'est premier degré il est prêt à se
marier avec vous alors bonjour voilà
c'est fini
sérieuse mais je voulais je vous fasse
passer le message qu'on aime ou pas oui
oui je vous donnerai son mot tout à
l'heure j'ai un regret de qui s'agit il
a dit je suis célibataire mais non je me
marie direct avec elle si elle veut mais
de quel droit de savoir quand même où le
nom et entre vous je pouvais nouvelles
d'hier il m'a dit je peux le dire thiam
inquiète
on parle de l'histoire d'amour syrie il
y en a une qui est née sur notre plateau
cette semaine c'est qu' une nouvelle
idylle
oui mais alors ils se sont branchés un
petit peu sur plateau grâce à nos
talents d'autres médias mais en
coulisses a avancé un petit peu regardé
j'ai toutes les preuves de tout ramener
non mais si à 20 ans elle a dit halak n
qu'est ce que tu racontes là ni
[Musique]
tu n'as pas confiance du tout alors
qu'est très belle femme match que toi
moi je dis la vérité
demain tu me laisses m'occuper de toi je
te trouve 15 comme vous tournez toi
sentimentalement avait pas vu depuis un
petit moment mais ça va changer
diop et micro alors oui majoral au micro
[Applaudissements]
yann alors à moi c'est le petit look
baroudeur est tous là ça me va très bien
yann est ce que ça que c'est votre fils
daniel est ce que c'est votre style et
daniel c'est le style de tout le monde
l'aimait relayeuse étant donné qu'on
peut pas aller au restaurant ce moment
je vais vous installer une petite tape y
aura deux bougies
il y en aura une troisième qu'il faudra
retrouver devrait maintenant moins
d'avions
il trotte dans la tête pour regarder
j'enlève le modèle on attend série
[Musique]
j'aime bien quoi mais janot des mots
combinés baker le becquet non mais
[Musique]
babel j'ai envie de dire d'abord doubout
franchement très très bien oui ils sont
là ce soir et sont là je les ai ramenés
on va voir si ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on en est où daniel on est timide
on est timide mais moi je c'est vrai que
quand je me noie un peu dans ses yeux
car il a des yeux magnifiques
c'est un peu lubrique gentil salut prix
[Applaudissements]
il a fait des briquets je vous explique
les traiteurs caché grand traiteur plus
brigitte et 3 de la pris çà sans droit
le bric crois que c'est une bille
brigade hav fr une brique une brique à
neige alors oui est-ce que ça va avancer
cette affaire avec daniel parce que je
vous si je peux me permettre je vous
trouve même des preuves sur tous les
dossiers
c'est moi je suis prêt et l'immédiat
nous parce que quand vous m'avez
présenter l'autre jour j'ai eu après les
tweets
oui fait attention il ya une axel dans
l'eau alors demandé aujourd'hui elle est
blonde alors alors là je suis
complètement subjugué par daniel wallace
rugby oui subjugué sait le faire
ça marche pas et donc voila mais par
contre je crois que daniel à me répond
pas j'essaye mais je suis hyper team et
le baiia et il est splendide
hazard ou sow
denner non mais c'est un des plus beaux
hommes que j'ai vu deux visages
c'est pas parce a accordé une victoire
tu m'as déjà pris patrick hein ah ouais
c'est dégueulasse et malin venue la
patrie patrick en exil mais il est parti
dans les montagnes chalet avec son chien
à poil après alors je vois pas ci fais
pas ça bien sûr on va suivre l'histoire
mais plaisir et semaine prochaine je
vais organiser un dîner
dommage ce qui m'a mis dans ma loge on
peut pas l'horizon à champcevinel tous
les deux dans ma loge tous les deux mois
je pense que pour jeu coudre un petit
coup de pouce vous dire je vais essayer
en laponie gpac m
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
brouillette
le choix
merci l'amour sera pas la dame que
daniel préfère l'amour en mer avant de
repartir cyril avec moi vous avez fait
une rubrique de 45 g et des invités ont
tels que ça nous coûte cher
mes parents par kg / diffusé le fait que
vous soyez un amour de patron je montre
chaque semaine aux accusateurs que vous
êtes un amour il était rien et 17
secondes on va être en direct la dent 13
secondes deux choses à savoir 1 me
cassez pas les couilles de me demandez
pas l'argent qui est opérée pas car tu
sais pas pour vous les poudres mais
nouveauté des mois les nouveaux 20,6
équation 50 et à sa soeur qu'il va
passer mais continue tranquille il ya
obama 20h40 mais qui n'ont pas mâché
m'ont pas dit non on va basse très bon
pour nous au contraire
faut-il compter lorsque jean d'arc a
sauté de griffoul adelheid en mettant le
ouais ouais sa grand-mère nadège
[Applaudissements]
un maximum et qui jouent samedi dès le
12 mai
là ils adorent ça